okay hello everyone I would like to
welcome you to this webinar on COC
genomics workbench twitty
bailable desktop software to engineer
data analysis my name is life Sheldon
I'm the director of product management
of genome analysis in cotton and I have
a PhD in plant molecular genetics from
Aarhus University which is located in
Denmark after PhD I went for posture
postdoctoral training in Norwich in the
UK and then I came back to become
professor and bioinformatics at Aarhus
University and in 2013 I joined the
company you know in Aarhus that is
called CLT bio which was a good position
by kayaks in just two months after I
joined and I've been here since
so today I wanted to tell you a little
bit but about the new capabilities we
have developed in the workbench but
before I do that I wanted to show Haley
daddy claimer and share the agenda with
you so I will introduce the genomics
workbench and focus on what's new in the
workbench and I will also talk about a
new release plugin for long raid support
which is for Oxford nanopore reads and
tactile reads and I also present the
roadmap for this year's developments
which we will really end of the year or
next year and then I will demo the
software for you and how to run how to
how to run the software and not what the
user interface looks like how to install
and run tools from the plugins and
modules and how to page analysis if you
have many samples in how to control
workflows
so the COC genomics workbench has been
around for many years like it was the
first commercial software for NGS
analysis so we've been working on this
for 15 years or more and what it
basically does is it's a cross-platform
desktop genomics application with a
graphical user interface so it has a
user-friendly interface it has a lot of
interactive visualizations to facilitate
analysis and it has many ready-to-use
and customizable workflows that allow
you to automate processing fast queue
files and you can share these workflows
with your colleagues and over over the
world it has a modular design so the
core is shipped at the genomics
workbench and a lot of additional
functionality can be loaded into the
workbench to the plugins depending on
your special interest its development
the quality control of isosurface
certified by the German authorities and
then it works on Windows and Mac and
Linux then supports most sequencing
platforms so that's yurina torrent
Oxford nanopore Pacific Biosciences in
the PGI MGI and sequencing
so scalable to enterprise the wide
support deployment so we have software
for that also I will present to you
and finally the
capabilities are fully documented and
also supported
so I will start with the enterprise
solutions because that's maybe
one of the key features that is often
missed when when we present the software
but actually we are fully scalable to to
enterprise wide and also institutional
lightsome the whole whole Institute of
the University can can subscribe to a
server if they have if they have some
hardware the background so this hardware
is then the server infrastructure or the
high performance compute of your
Institute and you would access the
service server software and the server
software comes with two kinds of clients
one of them are the work benches and
another client is the command-line tools
so plan competitions and can can access
directly the tools from the command line
they want to do that you can unlock the
server with with the plugins and with
also external applications if you have
that sure can be anything a freeware
commercial software third party
the second enterprise solution that we
have launched more recently and are
wrapping up on is called the EOC
genomics cloud engine which works by
deploying the local
clients that could be the server through
all the workbenches or the command line
and then directly interact with your
cloud instance Amazon Web Services and
that's that's pretty powerful because it
allows you to bypass the whole title
department and the costs that come with
maintaining a high computing facility in
this case exactly a 30-mile group so
that was just a short introduction to
the enterprise level now I want to talk
about the workbench and it's black plug
in application so the workbench contains
all the classical molecular biology
tools that you may already know from the
main workbench that we also have a
product and all of those are included in
the genomics workbench
you can do your vascular trimming and
pre-processing of NGS data just like any
other pipeline out there we have large
capability for our Nasik differential
expression and statistical analysis and
also extendable to small RNA click data
and in micronics we have her capability
to detect another transcript and we are
very good at the de novo assembly of
both genomes mega genomes meet a
transcriptome identify rome's whatever
you can generate annotate and compare
high confidence variant calls or for
biomedical purposes for example but also
for virus outbreak to call ships you can
do epigenetic analysis on NGS data and
if you happen to be a classic panel
customer then we have an extensive
shudos through so that in the biomedical
let's plug in we also interface with the
tertiary analysis tools such as IPA
which is ingenuity pathway analysis and
qci which is catch in clinical insights
for variant interpretation that's a easy
management of reference data so if you
are working with any organism especially
in human loss and Rex we have exempted
collections of reference data that are
downloadable with with one or two clicks
less advanced workflow control that you
are given to contain to to control your
your advanced workflows and I will show
them in a in a few slides
and with the biomedical plugin
especially but also with the microbial
plugin and their extensive collections
of ready-to-use workflows that are free
optimized for the purpose at hand
and then microbial genomics analysis
plugin does but the amount of microbiome
and clinical microbiology and us to edge
a disposal
click a short you hear on the tool works
how that is organized you can see the
they are they are organized by soldiers
that are then named by the overarching
theme of the tools in that folder and so
the first couples are for non mgs data
example who movie sequence alignment
phylogenetic cloning tools
Sanger sequencing and so on the track
tools are really what one could call a
genome browser a genome viewer and all
the accessory tools that make it easy to
work with the prepare sequencing data
are then the QC tools for in NGS the
trimming tools and the de-multiplexing
facility then you have three sequencing
analysis and RNA second small RNA micro
RNA epigenomics the noble and installed
workflows and these are application
specific tools that are populated taller
or populated already when you download
the work at the workbench and others get
populated when you download specific
plugin
okay utility tools allow you to process
your your your object in the workbench
you can rename you can sample reads you
can extract reads from certain areas in
the aquino browser and so on and then
the legacy tools are tools that will be
retired in the next version just to give
a fair warning
so that was in the way the workbench as
it comes if you want to extend the
capabilities of the workbench you can do
that by installing downloading a lot of
different plugins we have a few
commercial plugins where you have to
license and mainly used one is the
microbial genomics module which is
useful for strain typing epidemiology
and antimicrobial resistance analysis
you can do with a genomic community
profiling and assemble and functional
analysis with the true it has rational
analysis tools and pre-built and user
customizable data bases and it's
integrated support for a specific
chiastic
16 X 9 th panel
the genome finishing module allows you
to automate and manually finish your
genomes and polishing so that could be
for example plasmids or smaller genomes
like like yeast genomes if you if you
don't get them finished in the first
iteration then there are a lot of tools
for primary winding and polishing later
caches and that comes with integrated
support for peg pile and Illumina hybrid
assembly in finishing so for the free
plugins we have to biomedical genomics
analysis plug-in that has all the
workflows for human mouse and dress then
we just launched the long reach support
plug-in and we'll show you that also in
a moment and we have a genome alignment
plugin which is still in beta but can be
used to align hundreds of bacterial
genomes or dozens of each size genomes
for synteny monitoring then let's upload
to the IPA in IPA and by these require
subscriptions of those capabilities with
the ingenuity back-end in order to be
useful we also have two third-party
plugins which are provided by third
party would like to go and make a gene
Mauch
I want to go into depth with a couple of
these capabilities from the plugins
where the Buy America genomic analysis
is maybe the one you would want to if
you're working with Mouse and Rec and
tumors and these have a lot of workflows
that are standard in in the in the field
for oncology but also for hereditary
and workflows so you can see family of
374 and so on they are in here for
somatic oncology it's two more normal
samples and and they are all slightly
different in what they use for variant
calling this different pair in color and
also what they use for filtering that is
very specific to the purpose at hand
in that
biomechanical genomics analysis plug in
death also a
launch facility for kai-shek panel
analysis and so here you have seven
eight tabs for different types of Chi
effect panels Tama for ela others are
for RNA and then used one is multimodal
which is a new panel that is both
starting RNA and painting
and these work with antara data as well
as for Illumina data and you can
go with the talents that are of the
catalogue of the shelf or you can head
in the custom panel that you enter
designed with with with kyochon jingle
the other panel sorry the other module I
would like to talk about is the
microbial genomics module and where you
have the tools for straight typing in a
video energy so taxonomic identification
mlst typing we have recently edited the
core genome and whole genome mlst and
there's a lot of content coming with
this module in the form of antimicrobial
resistant detection which is the most
comprehensive collection at this point
and also a large number of tutors I
think three different ways to to assess
whether there's any antimicrobial
resistance in your sample
and then finally outbreak tracing
capability is like citrus or minimum
spanning trees with photos
and you can overlay a rich amount of
state of metadata on these two to three
trace your outbreak for metagenomics we
have the catechol 16s ids amplicon base
microbiome profiling
and we also have from whole genome
shotgun metagenomics that allow you to
the taxonomic profiling just on the on
the whole genome shotgun grid and there
is a de novo assembly of those
metagenomic samples and gene level
functional profiling you can then
annotate your gene findings with base
blasted this diamond hit or with P found
two links and it's very easy to get
high-quality reference data through this
module
so which is the reference data manager
which allows you to pre-populate your
reference minute your reference data
just by clicking on selecting and
clicking on the reference data you are
most interested in and downloading it
and to your hard disk and for panels we
support that we offer a variety of panel
specific bed files that go with the
workflows that I just showed you
so what did we do for this release and
first we have already had this
functionality of this concept of
batching where you can iterate and
execute workflows overall input files
and so that's an old one and basically
the main functionality that we have
upgraded in the latest release and we
have done so by allowing you to batch
over multiple inputs so before it was
only one kind of input now you can have
multiple input to fetch over iterating
the same workflow for example you can
map several read maps and several reads
fast queue files to several references
and you can match them up by specifying
and this in metadata that controls them
the fetching
so that's the iterate over several input
governed by metadata you can on-the-fly
import NGS data so you start directly
from fast queue before you had to first
import the reads to the workers and you
can now export both SPS that's always
been the case but now you can also
export reports in a machine readable
format called JSON which then allows you
to take that structured output and
process with your favorite you know text
processing tool could be our
also release the ability to combine many
reports into a single report so that's
also a request that we've had for many
years to have that capabilities so I've
drawn an example of workflow here of the
Nara Nasik the pipeline where you would
use all of these capabilities so now you
can do rnaseq in a single workflow and
starting with many samples that iterate
over the conditions that are specified
in the metadata could be time could be
drug treatment or a combination of both
and you can then combine the
quantitation of these RNA sic mappings
and make pairwise comparison all against
all in all against reference it's like
and again is governed by the metadata
you can export results with PDF or JSON
and you can combine the old of the
intermittent results into a single
report to very quickly get a get an
overview of which samples have not
performed or which step has been
critical and so
so here's an example of the iterate
workflow control element to work flow
control elements we've added to the
collection of work flow control elements
one's called iterate the other ones
collect and distribute and so here I'm
showing the iterate in this example you
would take
several past few files and map to
several references and that can be
specified in the metadata
yes
here here I show how to specify that in
the in the metadata so the metadata for
example matches up to Salmonella or
materia and the metadata the references
matches the Manila and Nigeria to the
reference genomes so that way the
functionality of this new worker element
is fully aware of what to
match with what
for the collect and distribute workflow
control element you need to provide a
comma-separated list of terms in the
output field and let's define the number
of output channels and their names and
then after selecting the approach the
page units and the collect units must be
specified using a metadata table so you
can see again this is making heavy
heavily use of the metadata which may be
a little different from how you usually
use the workbench but we strongly
encourage you to to reduce these
capabilities as they are really powerful
if you are scaling up your research
which was the headline of last year
development enabling scaling up of
research and the metadata table are
really easy to construct you can either
do that within the workbench or you can
simply do that in your favorite program
excel for example and just import it
from there and create a mega take a
table and then link it to the data and
to the ID words you want to use
with that
um the combined reports to is also new
as I mentioned earlier and you can set
it up if you want the report can
original contour Asianet from one sample
so if one workflow has many steps and
create many reports you can
create this report of reports or
combined reports on that one sample from
almost that to quickly get an overview
and but you can also do it for several
examples in one report so that you can
quickly spot outliers and deviant
examples summary information is shown as
plot
and
it includes tables for outliers
so this is what it looks like
you have the overview table and this is
a cheesy content of a number of samples
and then you can also have the summary
plot view and lettuce shows you how
where the outliers are and they
authorized by the way also colored
yellow in the first table and then in
the summary table you you get the rating
Samurai
so iterate and combine reports in this
workflow the our Nasik analysis tool can
be run once per sample and here at the
same time as creating the single
combined report for whole batch of
samples so that's very useful in certain
scenarios where you typically
20 input files and you don't want to
look through 10 or 20 reports or maybe
money Morris is because for every sample
you may generate several reports by the
workflow in this case it's only one
we also released other products so this
was January release sorry separately
where we release the main workbench that
kills the genomics weapons and the
biomedical genomic analysis plug-in and
for the main workbench we release the
biomolecule generator tool to generate
or extract biomolecules paper symmetry
information in PD P files and you can
also use a - now that homology modeling
of a sequence and the molecular
structure in a malefic molecule project
can be exported to be PDB file and with
continued functionality so these are
protein structure capabilities that we
have included in the main workbench only
now
I already talked about the genomics
workbench improvement let's go skip that
for the biomedical genomic analysis
plug-in we have added and three a new
panels support for kya SEC panels and
one of them is the multimodal panel and
second one is the chaotic fusion XP
which includes the variant calling you
can detection and expression
quantification and fusion detected
fusion it is shown in the figure and
finally we have released the targeted
methylation analysis capability from our
classic and on it with the same name
the microbial genomics module has
released strain typing improvements so
that you now can do core genome and
whole genome and industry and with that
we have released minimum spanning trees
visualization of the MMSE data and
that's what's shown in this graph and we
have updated the antimicrobial
resistance with integration into public
databases and content curation so
especially the the card and database has
been added
um in January suggest month ago we
released the QC long reach support
plug-in and this is a new plugin that
targets the tactile users and the Oxford
nanopore users so you can now let these
long reads to reference you can deliver
example with long and short reads you
can polish with luminaries you can
correct language and you can use long
reads as context schedules for lumen
assembly so these are
five different tools that come as part
of this plugin and can be used in new
bottles and these are mini workflows
here but you can make more with more
complex ones
and the roadmap for for COC in 2020 what
we will do this year is to continue our
work on longer it supports so hopefully
we will get to do long assemblies maybe
even for deployed species and for will
support microbiome and meta genome
analysis for taxonomic profiling and the
kind of assemblies we will to various
user experience updates to make it more
user friendly
[Music]
then we have a big project on
single-cell analysis where we want to go
from vacuum files to trapeze me plots
and and allow the customers to to
clustering on those and we will
introduce a couple of new high-tech
panel supports and one is for the t-cell
repertoire
[Music]
a receptor repertoire analysis and the
other one is for human exome panels on
the cloud side we will give users
directly access from the workbench to
base phase to the base based accounts
and finally we will introduce a paper
sample QC analysis in the clouds and
crash and hosted
so in summary I have presented to you
the workbench and its features an
overview of the toolbox and I have shown
what's new then in the latest release
and how to do on the fire import from
task you how to batch over multiple
input and shown the new control elements
iterate and collect and distribute I've
presented them combined with thoughts to
explore of data and Jason the long lead
and analysis support plugin and the
roadmap for 2020
so this is the workbench once you've
opened it
its main area is this workbench area
where we have prefilled items that help
you with quicker and easier onboarding
if it's the first time you're here or
you open it after a longer while absence
you can open the Welcome Center which
will display the new features and new
tutorials and and whatnot that we have
published over the last few months you
can quickly get started on your favorite
topic that could be a variant calling a
resequencing they know assembly
expression epigenetics oh and anything
that you are particularly interested in
then we have access to tutorials here
and the manual here otherwise the data
is in Windows like folder structure here
where you can view what what is a in
your workbench instance on on the data
front you can pre-fill the example data
by going to help and then say import
example data and it will copy for you
from the from our Kuragin home page this
small set of of example data so that you
can get
started in the toolbox you have all the
tools that are available to you in a
fuller structure that is logically
adhering to what the intention of these
tools is so for classical sequence
analysis for example you would have
alignment and trees general sequence
alignment error analysis nucleotide
analysis protein analysis and protein
structure and so on for all the other
tool collections in the workbench here
you can create News you'll see objects
that could be folders or adapter lists
or metadata tables but you can also
import these by clicking import if you
have them from an excel file for example
you can very easily import metadata from
from an excel file that you have on your
desk on your drive you can also import
all kinds of reads Oxford nanopore
aluminum and Traxxas for the primer and
bed files that come with many panels for
specific panels and primer pairs has
also specialized support down here you
can export all kinds of objects in
different formats the latest support
that I mentioned in the slide tech
before is JSON that is a machine
readable format that from your reports
you can again launch your favorite tools
from the rocket icon and simply start
typing what you want to do say local
realignment
then you can get the tool here and
double-click on it
you can decide where to run it and it
will ask you for input data and
parameters and if you're not sure how to
set those parameters or if you would
like to understand how what the defaults
mean you can ask the Help button to
bring you to the exact location in the
manual and which describes this step
over here we have manager tools one is
the plugin manager which will populate a
list for you if you're online with all
the plugins that are available for you
that exactly match the version of the
workbench that you have and you can
download and install these some of them
will be commercial and cost you another
license and others will be for free and
they extend the functionality of the
workbench lastly so these are the
plugins then that you have already
installed so you can disable them or
under stall them and then reinstall them
from here as there's new updates you can
quickly manage your reference data here
depending on what organisms you are
working with that's the long range of
pre-selected species for you that gives
you access to post the sequence but also
the annotations and variants if that's
of interest to you we also have
collections that we maintain which are
more specialized to certain workflows
that we provide for example in the in
the biomedical space there's a lot of
human sets that pre-populated with both
sequence but also the annotations and
resources that are very handy to have in
the workflow
for filtering out population variance or
something like that here you have a
download facility for short read archive
access or for for downloading sequences
from NCBI directly into your workbench
and finally here is the workbench
Manager sorry the the workflow manager
that allows you to design new workflows
so you can add elements by either
selecting them from here or by dragging
them in from from from this one the
toolbox map reads for example sorry map
which to reference so then you can
connect things to each other and make a
quick web flow here that would do re
trimming and mapping to the reference
and give you a track of that that you
can view in the genome browser
afterwards so that's a quick way to make
your custom made by informatics pipeline
if you want to have workflows that we
provide for you you can go into this
ready to use workflow for example and
take your favorite say you want to
identify variants with whole genome
sequencing you can open a copy of this
workflow and inspect the elements what
what is it actually doing for you and
what are the settings of the parameters
you can you can see that by
double-clicking on the tool and then
going to the configure panel and again
you can click the help menu if you if
you're looking for specifics on on the
parameters okay then
one of the more specialized
functionalities for those of you who
work with the chiastic panel is this
so we have a number of resources that
where you can find more information and
the main one is the theory genomics
workbench homepage and then you can find
a number of tutorials manuals and
frequently asked questions that will get
you started
especially that tutorial and get started
with the COC genomes workbench it could
be very useful and you can add an
overview of the plugins either from
within the software if you have already
obtained that or from this help homepage
and this all the plugins that are
available and finally keep an eye on our
block and maybe subscribe to it because
that's where we can you know show off
our newest capability at any time
okay so if you have any questions feel
free to submit these to the chat box and
I will answer them and if we have more
questions than the time allows then I
will email them answers to you by and
after the presentation
okay so first question do you have a
support organization and dessert and
options for purchasing taylor plan
dramatic solutions and yes thanks for
that question
indeed we have a support organization
based in Denmark California and India so
they are providing 24 5 and you can
easily contact them by email from within
the software and they'll get back to you
with competent guidance very fast and
for title act offerings we have a
dedicated team performance performing
what we call managed services across the
coyote and digital impact portfolio if
you want for example to extend the
functionality of CLC or have a cloud
hosted solution of a complete fast q2
insight by informatics solution then we
can should do that
okay here's another question I have few
skills in a workbench while at the
University before is that a completely
different product so as I think I said
in the beginning here we have the main
workbench also as such as the product
which contains the empirical cloning
tools Brown design Sanger sequencing
handling multiple sequence alignment
hello genetic rebuilding etcetera so you
can say this is our entry-level product
the COC genomics workbench has the main
workbench functionality 100% included in
addition to all the NGS handy tools so
the genomic workbench is the analysis
work house workhorse and the offer to
move or smaller lab and if you want to
then go
Enterprise five we have the server and
the cloud engine
the look and feel and the tools and the
workflows algorithms are shared between
these software levels
so here's a question what is the
licensing model for co2 genomics
workbench
so we just shifted from perpetual
license to actually subscription license
that makes this product much cheaper so
we have an annual subscription license
that you can subscribe to and there's
two types of those one is a desktop
license which are locked to a single
machine and the other type are network
licenses which are floating in your
network and can be checked out by
individual users at any machine in the
network and you can borrow a license
from the network if you go on a field
trip for example
here's a question how does our software
your software compared to offerings by
other vendors or freeware mmm that's a
good question so COC has been a first
mover in this space of Europe and the
desktop software for NGS analysis but in
the last five years we've seen many
copycats offerings in the commercial
space but none of them is anywhere as
comprehensive it's CLC now for some
cloud vendors they still require
command-line scripting and where our CLC
cloud engine combines the usability of
the of the work bench with the power of
the cloud engine so no snow
come on logical thing is required that
second part of the question for freeware
so that's thousands of tools out there
you know developer universities and
research institutes around the world and
but none of them has has managed to
deliver comprehensive user-friendly and
easy to install and deploy a desktop
solution so these are typically
command-line tools collections of those
that are maintained in get happen T in
distributed and give up so you really
need a little specialist in your team to
install and maintain these products and
in addition then the documentation
remains fragmented and you would have a
very very sparse random support so
that's the main difference